[CREAK]
[WHOOSH]
[TAPPING]
AUDIENCE: So I should
talk with him directly?
HALSEY BURGUND:
Yeah, so thank you.
I was extremely
excited when I learned
that this class was happening
at all, just because I've
been doing things that I would
consider audio AR for 12 years
now, probably.
I'm very old, so don't
ask me any particulars.
And it's so exciting
to be at a time
now where things are
becoming, I don't
know if I'd call it
mainstream yet, but at least
getting to the point where
people are talking about it
and teaching it.
And so I was excited to
learn from what you guys are
going through and
learning in this class
and to contribute to
the extent that I can.
So I don't know what
just happened there,
but I'm going to
press Play again.
Am I back?
I'm a sound artist
and technologist.
And I've been doing
work with what
I would call audio AR for
quite a while, as I was saying.
I work a lot with
spoken human voices.
And the contributory
part of my work
is that I generally
do work that feeds off
of responses and commentary
that I get from people
who are experiencing the work.
So I ask people questions.
I record their answers,
or they record themselves.
And then those sort of feed
back into these evolving
works that are
often location-based
and change over time and often
have a musical underpinning,
as well.
So I'm going to talk about
a whole bunch of examples
of my work and then talk a
little bit about the technology
that I've developed to support
some of that work, which
is what I would call a
contributory audio AR framework
platform called Roundware.
And then I'm hoping
there'll be plenty
of time to ask questions.
Because that's
probably going to be
the most useful and
interesting part, perhaps.
So feel free to jump in any
time if you have questions.
But there will be time
at the end, either way.
So let me just leap in.
I don't know what order things
are going to happen here,
but I'm going to go
for it, whatever it is.
OK, so what is Roundware?
I just mentioned a little
bit about what Roundware is,
but essentially, Roundware is
a framework, or a platform,
depending on your
preference there,
that basically, it
allows to overlay
any kind of physical landscape
with a layer of audio.
And it's actually multiple
layers of audio that
can interact with each other.
And I have this
quick example here
of the basic elements of what a
Roundware installation covers.
So let's say you wanted to do
something on the Mall in DC.
And this is the mall.
And the first thing
Roundware allows you to do
is to create regions of
what I call ambient music.
Well, I don't call it--
lots of people call
things ambient music,
but it's sort of a continuous
layer of ambient sound.
And those, right
now, they're just
circles that are drawn here.
You could have any
shapes you want.
And basically, the
way to think about it
is each of these circles has a
different underlying ambient--
it doesn't have to be
ambient but, often,
in my case, it's
ambient-- soundtrack.
And as you walk from
one to the next,
one fades out, the other
one fades in, et cetera.
Here, you've got all
three of them playing.
So this is a way to
compose a piece of music
or a audio experience of some
sort that really is very highly
dependent on how somebody
traverses an actual terrain.
So this is quite
simplified in the sense
that there are only
circles here right now.
Roundware started out,
you could only do circles.
I've since moved on to polygons,
which is very exciting.
So you can draw just a
block, or you can just
draw right around here
on a map and basically
assign any audio to that.
And in addition to the
underlying, continuous layer
of audio, there are
two types of what
I call momentary audio that can
be interspersed within that.
They're usually smaller
bits, and they are usually
pieces of audio that play once.
Like, you get into the area,
and then it's triggered.
It will play once,
and then it'll
be done, as opposed to a
looping, ambient situation.
And those can be either
curated by the person
creating the projects--
me or whomever is
using Roundware--
or they can be added--
using the same app-- they can
be added by the people who
are experiencing the project.
So these red ones
are to indicate
that there's another
type of content, which
is a dynamic type of content,
which happens over time when
a particular piece is installed.
So if I installed this
in DC on January 1,
and the app was
released and people
could wander around
listening to everything which
was the ambient layer and
then these yellow dots,
and then they added
their own on top
of that to respond to
various questions that
are asked within the app--
and depending on what
the piece is about,
I can ask any question I want--
look at the clouds and
tell me what you think,
or tell me what this
building reminds you of,
or anything at all, describe the
person who just walked past you
or something like
that, there are
lots of explorations that can
be done-- but the point is
that these red ones are
indicative of a co-creation
element to what I do, a
contributory element, and a way
in which I lose control over a
lot of what the piece ends up
being, which is both exciting
and totally nerve-racking,
as I'm sure you can imagine.
But it's a crucial
part of my work
and of what Roundware allows.
Because, again, Roundware
was developed, obviously,
to scratch my own itch that
I had to create the pieces.
So I will keep on going.
I'm going to kind of
crank through some
of the history of where
Roundware came from just
relatively quickly, although I'm
going to show one video, which
I think will be useful.
So Roundware was actually
named because the first project
I did with it was called Round.
So this was a
project for a museum
outside of New York called
The Aldrich Contemporary Art
Museum.
And they asked me to
come in and do something
that would be slightly
resembling an audio tour
but not be an audio tour.
Because they really didn't
like the general approach
of audio tours to
sort of tell you
what you're supposed to think
about the artwork, et cetera,
et cetera.
And I decided that
what I would do
was basically create a sort
of soundtrack for the museum
so when people are
wandering around,
they could hear that, and
then infuse it with comments
that people made
about the artworks
in the museum that would be
heard when you were standing
in front of that artwork.
So you could be standing
in front of a painting,
and you could hear the curator's
remarks about the painting,
but then you could also hear
a six year old's comments
about the painting, as
well, and the idea of sort
of democratizing and
making art into something
that I feel it should
always be, which is
that anybody can appreciate it.
Anybody can like or
dislike anything,
and you don't need to
have a PhD in art history
or some kind of
critical discourse
to have that sort
of appreciation.
So that's where
Roundware came from.
The title, Round,
the reason I named it
that, which is somewhat
useful, perhaps, to understand,
is, first of all, King
Arthur's Round Table,
where everybody sits
around a round table,
and nobody's opinion is
more important than others,
and then, second of all, the
notion of a musical round.
Do you guys know what a musical
round is, like "Row, Row, Row,
Your Boat"?
And everybody's singing together
but kind of in an offset way,
which I think is
somewhat what Roundware
enables you to create.
So I'm going to hope
that this is actually
going to play a video.
This was a piece that I did
at the deCordova Sculpture
Garden and Museum out in
Lincoln, outside of Boston.
And it was one of the first
pieces using Roundware,
and I think it will
give you a little bit
of an idea of what
Roundware can actually do
and what my work is like.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HALSEY BURGUND: The
Scapes piece is,
I think of it as a musical
composition that is a spatially
related musical composition.
And the volumes of those
parts fade up and down,
depending on how
close you are to where
the center of that
particular musical part is.
- OK, let's walk.
The music is changing now.
Yeah, we get these bells
more towards-- the entrance
of the museum is more of
a sort of melodic part
of our slow melody.
All the music is
based on some of
the topographic characteristics
of the park itself.
- I know that--
- Oh, there's some voices.
- There's some voices.
- Hey, there goes a chipmunk.
- --somebody--
- Right where I'm standing,
some guys saw a chipmunk.
- There's a chipmunk.
- There goes the chipmunk again.
- Which could have been a
chipmunk from two weeks ago.
- Yes, it could have,
absolutely, which I think
is kind of fun to
think about where
that chipmunk is right now.
- [LAUGHS]
- --is getting what I would
call ominous, a little darker.
And as I'm standing
here, a huge, dark cloud
is rolling in over the
garden, over the trees.
The light's getting darker.
And I don't know how the
application [INAUDIBLE]..
- I'm standing inside
this glass sculpture.
And the acoustics are very fun.
- Oh, wow.
So that guy went and did this.
They stuck their head
into this open glass dome
that's part of the structure.
And these are the acoustics
he was talking about.
And now, I'm doing it, too.
- You might not have
done that otherwise.
- I'm pretty sure
I wouldn't have.
- [LAUGHS]
- In a week, they are recruiting
into the Israeli army.
I'm going to be a soldier.
I'm very scared, pretty excited.
Being here is pretty
peaceful, I guess,
compared to what I'm
about to go through.
Good luck to me.
- Oh, wow.
Is this rain?
- That's rain.
- Someone must have been
here when it was raining.
- And they recorded the rain
and left it here for us.
- It's not raining,
though, right now.
- No.
- That's pretty cool.
So if you want to make
your own recording.
- OK, I'm looking
at this sculpture.
It looks like a piece of like
HVAC duct work from a building,
but it kind of twists
in a way that reminds
me of a lower intestine.
And we hit stop?
- And hit stop, and then
we can listen to it back.
- OK, I'm looking
at this sculpture.
It looks like a piece of--
- There I am.
- --like HVAC duct work.
- There are at
least three elements
going on simultaneously.
There is the music.
There was the rain from god
knows when that was recorded,
not on a day like today.
And then, there's me.
- From just a few minutes ago.
- It looks like a
very peaceful garden.
The thing I think would
help it would be a few--
would be a few of one of those
type of fish that are catfish.
[END PLAYBACK]
HALSEY BURGUND: So
that should give you
a little bit of an idea.
So that piece started out
with just the music and none
of the comments.
And then, people made
the comments over time,
which, again, that's the other
sort of nerve-racking part
of this is when you start
and the music is written
to have comments on top of it,
so it's not that interesting
until commentary comes in.
But you hope for the
best and hope that you
get kids who like catfish.
I don't know.
"It's a type of fish that are
catfish" is very interesting
phrasing.
But super cute, though.
So that gives you
the basic idea,
I think, hopefully, with the
retro iPhone and everything.
So I'll go through--
actually, I'm going to skip
some of these things real quick
here.
That's not, that's
not, that's not--
OK, another audio
ARP, Sound Sky.
This was a piece I did in
Christchurch, New Zealand.
A number of years ago,
they had a huge earthquake
in Christchurch, which
pretty much destroyed
a huge portion of the downtown.
So the sort of hope
with this piece
was to create a piece
in the downtown area
and let people who are residents
go wander through and, in part,
reminisce about what used to
exist in certain places that
were, unfortunately,
destroyed but then also look
to the future and sort of talk
about, well, this was this,
but now we have an
opportunity to rebuild,
and this could become this, and
the downtown could transform
into this new sort of thing.
So the idea of having a
location-based piece that
allowed people to
make these comments,
to actually create the
comments when they're
in the emotional space of being
there, was extremely important.
Because I think that really
puts you in the right
place to make heartfelt,
earnest, authentic comments.
And then, also, obviously,
when other people come by
to listen to those comments,
they exist in the place
where the person made them.
So there's this connection
to the specific landscape,
to that specific location, on
both ends of that experience,
which I think is one of the ways
that audio AR can be really,
really compelling-- certainly
not the only but one
of the great ways that you
can navigate through a space,
listening to something,
and not having your phone
in front of you the
whole time, and get
that added layer of content.
So another project,
Tributaries, this
was a project in
Newcastle in the UK,
which was done for the 100th
anniversary of World War I--
the end of-- well, the entire--
a bunch of the
museums over there
were doing a bunch of
exhibitions on World War I.
And they wanted to try to bring
back some voices from back then
and bring back some
of the experiences
that people who were
alive then went through.
Obviously, there's
not many recordings
from back then, so we had
to reproduce some of that.
But they did have a lot
of text, a lot of diaries,
a lot of other--
there were weather reports
and all that kind of stuff.
So there were ways
that we could--
we got a present-day
weatherperson
to voice the weather
reports from a hundred years
ago and distribute those
throughout the city
and kind of create
this connection
between this historical
moment and the present day.
And I think, again,
I think audio,
and audio AR, in
particular, I think
can be very effective at
compressing time, if you will,
or connecting different
points in time,
whether it's
yesterday and today--
I experienced something
in this location now,
and somebody will have a new
experience in this location
tomorrow, and there's sort
of a constancy of location--
but a breadth of time, I think,
can be quite interesting.
And whether it's a day, a week,
a month, or a hundred years,
I think there's a lot of
ways of jumping into that
and doing some exploring.
So Tributaries,
that was probably
the biggest aspect
of that project that
was new and different for me.
So now, I'll get a little
into behind-the-scenes stuff--
not too much.
So as I mentioned
before, Roundware
is a software platform.
It is open source.
I'm not going to get really,
hardly at all, technical.
So I'm sure you guys are--
but feel free to ask
more technical questions
if you have them.
But Roundware, essentially,
is a client server.
The server sits in the cloud.
All the audio is
stored up there,
database, all that
kind of stuff.
And then there are
various clients
that can talk to that server
via the Roundware API.
This is a somewhat
old diagram, so
forgive some of the stuff
that's a little outdated.
But essentially, just
what I said-- database,
some software on the server that
used to do the audio mixing.
The audio mixing is now
moved to the clients.
But the basic point is that
there's a database of audio
that is all geotagged.
And the clients access that
data with the knowledge,
of course, of
where the client is
at any given time, how
the client's moving,
all of that information.
And that enables the generation
of a dynamic stream of audio
that is unique for
any individual.
Any client will have a
unique stream of audio,
whether it's coming
from the client
or being generated locally.
And it all depends on how
they're walking around,
how fast they're going,
in some cases, what
direction they're looking.
I know you guys are fully
aware of all the Bose stuff,
the frames and whatnot.
So that's a sort of
high-level architecture.
This is way more than I
want to actually go through.
As I mentioned, the mixing is
now done on the client side.
So just the component
parts of the audio stream
are downloaded.
And then, the client
does the mixing, which
allows me to do less
latent activities,
such as when you look in
a different direction,
you don't want to have to
wait for the buffering time
to have your audio actually
change accordingly.
So client-side mixing
makes a lot more sense
and is something
that we've moved to.
The iOS framework
has moved to that,
as has the web app framework.
Android is a little behind--
budgetary problems.
You know how it is,
open-source projects.
When I get an
enthusiastic Roundware
developer to participate, then
that will catch up, I think.
But yeah, so frameworks for iOS,
you can put it into any iOS app
you want.
And it basically just
implements the Roundware API,
allows for the generation
of these streams
and the communication
with the server.
This is a diagram
of the playlist.
So essentially,
at any given time,
there's a dynamic playlist
that Roundware generates,
which determines
what of those assets
will play back for the person.
And the assets are, if you
remember the diagram before,
the small dots.
You could be in a spot where
there are a hundred assets.
You don't want to hear them all
at the same time, obviously.
You want to have
some kind of capacity
for filtering and whatnot.
So here's just a high-level
view of the filtering
that's possible.
You have all the
assets on the top
and then, for a
particular project,
then you can filter
them by tags.
Basically, it's very
simple metadata kind
of tags that are
grouped by categories.
Which question are
you responding to?
Are you an adult or a child,
if you care about that?
What's your favorite color?
I mean, it could be anything.
And then, there are
location-based filters
based on where you're
located, based on whether you
heard the asset recently.
And if it's been
blocked for some reason,
then there's ordering and
prioritization, all that kind
of stuff.
So again, I don't want
to go into huge detail
because we don't
have a ton of time.
But it's important,
obviously, to be
able to filter content
to be able to create
the kind of experiences
that you want.
And some of this content
filtering is automatic,
and others can be exposed to
the user based on what you want.
So in some cases, I might
want people to be able to say,
I want to hear only comments
that museum visitors have made
versus curatorial comments.
In other cases, I
might want to enforce
that those are mixed
with each other
to make some kind of
point, for example.
So here's a few other types.
These are kind of different
listening modes, if you will,
that Roundware supports.
The traditional
mode is when you're
within the range of
a particular asset,
it becomes part of the playlist.
So right here, these
three are in range.
They're either circles, or you
can have a polygon for assets,
as well.
That's pretty straightforward.
Whatever you're close
to, you can hear.
The global listen just
makes everything available,
no matter where you are.
That can be very
effective at times
for certain types of projects.
Or at certain times within
the experience of a project,
you could switch to
global mode and then
switch back, if you wanted.
Range listening allows
for you to create
some different
approaches of listening
to stuff that's at different
distances from you.
So there's a minimum
and a maximum distance.
I've done some experimentation
with-- lift your phone up
and it lets you listen to stuff
that's farther away from you.
And you point it downwards,
it brings the stuff closer.
So again, that's a way that
you can determine what content
you're listening to.
And that's useful if
you create projects
that don't have
content everywhere,
and you want people to
still be able to listen.
They can just
expand their range.
And then directional listening.
Again, this is
what Bose Frames do
but also the IMU
on your phone does.
So if you take your phone when
you're listening to the app
and you just move it around, you
can give yourself a certain arc
and listen to the content.
In this case, these three
guys would be available.
You can combine these
in different ways.
You can use the distance--
minimum and maximum distance--
with the range.
You can combine these sort of
approaches in different ways.
So I'm not going to demo the
web admin because I don't
think that's very exciting.
But I'm happy to answer
questions about that.
And we're coming
up on 4:30 here,
so I thought it would probably
be better for you guys
to have me stop blabbing
a lot and perhaps dive
into what is most interesting
to you guys-- hopefully,
something.
And we can go from there.
Is that cool?
Does that work for you guys?
I can certainly talk
about more projects,
but I'd love to hear what
questions you guys have.
And I can certainly demonstrate
stuff, as well if you want.
Questions?
Comments?
There's got to be something.
There's got to be.
AUDIENCE: One of
our first game ideas
that we haven't
ended up pursuing
was actually Gwen's idea,
but was this murder mystery,
where you have to go
to different locations
to get different clues,
to hear different clues.
The idea was you'd
go back in time
and hear something
relevant to whatever case
you're trying to solve
and that sort of thing.
HALSEY BURGUND: Yeah,
that's super cool.
AUDIENCE: That sounds like it
would be an application of--
HALSEY BURGUND: Totally.
Yeah, no, I love that idea.
I think the time
traveling thing,
as I was mentioning
before, I think
that can be really helpful.
You can create soundscape.
You could have a horse and
buggy driving by-- whatever.
You could have
period-type sounds
going if you wanted to
really make somebody feel
like they've gone back in time.
AUDIENCE: We could
personalize that for each user
so each user could be doing a
different story or something.
HALSEY BURGUND: Yes.
That would probably
be a set of tags.
You would assign different
tags to different stories.
You could have story
A, story B, story C,
and people would choose,
or could be assigned,
one of those three.
And then, that would
segment the content
based on what they wanted.
But yes, going to a
particular location,
gathering more
information or something
like that for the murder
mystery is definitely something
that Roundware could do.
It's actually funny.
Actually, that Scapes
piece, the Scapes piece
that I showed the
video of, people
started making up their
own games with it.
And one person did kind
of what you're saying.
It wasn't a murder
mystery, by any stretch,
but they went to a
random place and said,
go to the corner
of the parking lot
to receive further instructions
or something like that.
And then, they went over
there, and then they
proceeded to talk about
the further instruction.
And it was kind of a game
within the piece, which I didn't
have anything to do with that.
It was somebody taking their own
initiative to figure that out,
which I thought was great.
A whole bunch of kids talked
about zombies and stuff.
They were like, I'm hiding
beneath this sculpture.
The zombies are coming.
And then this story of zombies
actually continued over months,
with different people.
All the zombie fans
kind of came together.
And there was this one
area of the sculpture park
that kind of turned
into zombie land.
And then, at the end,
you'll be very glad to know,
the helicopters came and
landed, and everybody was saved.
So nobody died.
But obviously, the zombies are--
AUDIENCE: They're never leaving.
HALSEY BURGUND: I don't
know what they are.
I'm not going to make a comment.
I'm not going to come down
on one side of that argument.
But it's just one
of those things
where, when you
open up your work
to this kind of potential
interaction with it,
you sometimes get really,
really neat takes on it.
I mean, I certainly
didn't think to create
some kind of zombie scenario.
But it's wonderful.
And it adds-- to me, it
adds to the excitement
of creating these pieces.
My work is very, I
guess, maybe it's
a fear of ever having
something be done.
But there's something
about knowing
that things can be
sent out into the world
and kind of take
on their own life,
if you will, much
like a zombie--
no--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
HALSEY BURGUND: --and get this
level of creativity or level
of input that I
couldn't do on my own.
I really get tons of
inspiration from people
who come in and do stuff.
So yeah, I think that
idea is certainly
one that would be
well-suited for Roundware.
I have dreams of Roundware
becoming a SaaS at some point.
It is not yet.
It requires a little more
technical involvement
to set up the server and
then get the client talking
to the server.
All the code is there.
It's just a matter of
going through those steps.
There's a demo
Roundware app that
can be used for testing
stuff, which is pretty handy.
If you just want to go
out and make recordings
in certain locations and
then see how it works,
that can be done.
The iOS version is a
good place to do that.
But I think that idea
would definitely be--
Roundware could
certainly help at least
get the basics going on that.
AUDIENCE: Question.
HALSEY BURGUND: Yes?
AUDIENCE: You showed a
little bit of the Scapes user
interface for the
end user, where
they can record it and
just pretty much just drop
a sound that has some radius.
But then, you also showed
all this other capacity
of direction and like
minimum and maximum radius.
How much of that
do you see being
useful to expose to the most
typical part of the project,
right, and how much of it
is just too complex, I mean,
is off-putting?
HALSEY BURGUND: Yeah, to date,
I've exposed very little of it.
And that's a really
good question.
It is something I think
a lot about because I do
want it to remain
simple for the end user.
That's why there's two buttons.
It's Listen or Speak.
And obviously, within
Speak, there's a few steps
that you need to do--
what question do you want
to respond to and whatnot.
But it's fairly
straightforward in that regard.
And exposing more does cause
some problems sometimes.
So I've experimented
a little bit
with adding additional
filtering capacity
but having it semi-hidden--
not really hidden,
but it's behind a button.
You hit a button.
Then you open up, oh, here
are some filters I can do.
And the filters have
a default state,
which is basically
listen to everything.
And then you can
specify from there
and become a super-user
of sorts, if you want.
AUDIENCE: So this a user
choosing their listening
experience based on
eliminating things
that they don't want to hear.
HALSEY BURGUND: In
this case, yes, yes.
I like to start
with the broad set.
If you start with
nothing, then people
are going to get confused, so
kind of starting broad and then
narrowing down.
As far as the other listening
modes and everything goes,
that's more of a
set up the project
that way, one way or the other.
And if you're
seeding the project
with a certain
amount of content--
like the Scapes piece was seeded
with basically no content.
I allowed people to come in
and do whatever they wanted.
The Tributaries piece, I
created a lot of content myself,
and I put it out there--
the weather reports and diary
entries and machinist's shop
logs, stuff like that that
was historical material.
I could create that,
and then I could
place that where I wanted,
and I could create the shapes.
And I could do
anything like that.
Actually, the scenario in
which I think exposing more
to an end user that
would be most appropriate
would be something
that I'm working
on now, which is
enabling the app
to be a different
type of creation tool.
So the person creating
the experience
would be able to go and
say Create a Recording
and then walk around
a closed polygon
that they want that recording
to exist in, for example,
and do other manipulations--
be able to move stuff around,
to be able to adjust.
So you're really in the
actual physical location
that the piece is
going to be experienced
when you're creating it.
Because I think that's a far cry
from sitting at your computer
at a Google map and
drawing something.
Like, I think this is where it
is, but I'm not really sure,
and I don't really know
if this is going to work.
So you do that.
I always find myself doing
that and then going out
and listening and
then going back in.
And this back and forth
can be very frustrating.
So I think the exposure
of more in-depth
I don't know if you want to
call them editing tools or just
experience-modifying
tools, i think
makes more sense for more
the creator's side of things.
Of course, end
users are creators,
to a certain extent because
they have the option
of adding their own content.
But it's a good question.
Because I think it's
a constant balance.
And maybe when people
get more familiar
with the overall
idea of audio AR,
then we'll be able to
push a little farther
in that direction.
But right now, my experience
has been that people,
when explaining it to them, it
was wonderful when Pokmon GO
came out for me.
Because even though this
really isn't Pokmon GO,
there is an element of,
hey, it's like Pokmon GO,
except instead of finding
Pokmon, you're going around,
and you're finding
little pieces of audio.
And those are playing.
AUDIENCE: And you
can put some down.
HALSEY BURGUND: And
you can add-- right.
Pokmon, you can't spawn
your own Pokmon, really,
at this point.
But that was a nice
thing to give me
a context within which
to talk about this stuff,
despite the obvious differences.
But perhaps, when AR
generally and maybe audio AR
gets to the point where
everybody understands
that it exists and there are
possibilities on a base level,
then we'll be able to
push things farther.
But yeah, I think there's a ton
of stuff with the directional.
And that's why the Bose
IMU-enabled headphones
or frames-- and I know that
there are other manufacturers
doing stuff, as well.
And I think that's going to
be really exciting, for sure.
Or AirPods, I think they've
got IMUs or some semi-IMU.
The new AirPod Pros
have something.
They certainly have an
accelerometer in them.
So I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Well,
yeah, that's right.
Because you can tap them.
HALSEY BURGUND: Yeah,
because you could tap them.
And I don't know
what kind of APIs
are going to open up on that.
But it seems like people are
thinking about that stuff--
wearables, hearables.
I don't know if I'm
too into that phrase,
but it seems to be what
people are using somewhat now.
But yeah, for me,
the more hardware
that companies put out
that I can experiment with,
the better.
It's great because I certainly
can't build hardware.
I tried strapping an IMU to my--
it was a major failure.
But I'm not really
a hardware guy.
So more questions,
more comments,
more things you would
like me to show?
I can go to--
AUDIENCE: Just a take question.
What is the precision
where you delineate
where the song will play?
How exact is it?
HALSEY BURGUND: Well, Roundware
is what I would call location--
it's agnostic to where it gets
its location information from.
So you note I showed you
mainly outdoor projects.
Because we all know the
problems with GPS indoors.
We also know that GPS is the
only ubiquitous free location
technology that
exists right now.
So we have GPS error bars right
now, which, inside a building,
are way too big
to make it useful.
I have done a lot
of experimentation
with other interior
systems, whether they
be beacon-based or
magnetic field-based
or visual positioning systems.
But at the end of the
day, at this point,
Roundware just takes
two coordinates.
Roundware doesn't have
a z-axis at this point.
But adding that
isn't a huge leap.
But I haven't
bothered to add it.
There's no point until
I can get something
that actually gives me useful z
data to actually base something
off.
But it would be super cool if--
you get UWB systems,
which are like--
AUDIENCE: What's that?
HALSEY BURGUND: Ultra wideband.
You can get millimeter-level.
And then you could
raise your phone up,
and you could stand up and sit
down and get whole new levels
of ambient sound.
I mean, it could
be totally amazing.
But unfortunately,
Roundware depends
on the systems that are built by
large companies and governments
that I don't have
any control over.
AUDIENCE: But your experience
with implementing this museum
park walk, or art exhibit,
did it feel like it connected
spatially and conceptually.
It felt very connected
in the demo of,
oh, he must have been talking
about this particular thing.
But was that the experience when
you implemented it, as well,
that, yeah, people
really can see what
object they're talking about?
Or does it sort of pop up in
the wrong place sometimes?
HALSEY BURGUND: It would be
unfair of me to say that it was
always fine because
it certainly wasn't.
Sometimes GPS gets wacky.
And, of course,
the error bars get
multiplied because
you make a recording,
and there's an error bar
associated with that.
And then, you're listening
to the recording,
there's another
error bar associated.
Sometimes those
can destructively
interact, which is
great, other times not.
So certainly, there are times
when weird stuff happens.
I think, generally, I
was pretty aware of what
the error bars were when I
was creating the experience.
So I could set things up to a
certain extent understanding
that and guiding
the experience such
that it would work
relatively well with that.
But I will also say
that, as an artist,
I have it a little bit easier.
Because people are a
little more willing,
with aesthetic experiences,
a little more willing
to be forgiving about
stuff like that.
So if you're talking about
something that is maybe
over there, you'd be
like, oh, well, the artist
wanted me to walk over there.
I mean, if you're in a generous
kind of interpretive mode,
that can work.
I will say that, a lot of
times, little GPS hiccups
can actually be
really interesting.
Because if you're walking
by and somebody's like--
this happened to me
in the Scapes project,
just to use that as an example--
I was walking by, and
somebody was like,
I'm standing inside
this ring of trees,
and I'm looking up
towards the sky.
And it reminds me of
my grandfather's house
up in Maine, where I had
this similar situation.
I was like, I'm not in A
ring of trees right now.
I'm just walking
out in this field.
So it made me look around.
And I was like, oh,
30 feet that direction
was, in fact, something that
looked like a ring of trees.
And it got me to go into it.
So I think there is something
really nice about sort
of this audio AR generally
being able to kind of pull you
in different directions
or guide you or encourage
or whatever words
you want but to get
you to explore a little more
by giving you information that
is pertinent to a spot when
you're not quite at that spot
yet, for example.
And I know that might seem
like an excuse for GPS errors.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Yeah, I can see that.
HALSEY BURGUND: But
sometimes, they can be nice.
Of course, sometimes they
can be inappropriate and bad.
But you've got to open yourself
up to the goods and the bads.
But yeah, I'm just super
excited for the day when
interior positioning is accurate
enough to really do something
where you can place
sound objects,
walk around them, and have
them feel like they've
been spatialized and really
get a much more true-to-reality
kind of experience.
But you guys probably
know more about
how close we are
to that than I do.
But from where I sit,
exciting stuff is happening.
But it's still--
I mean, the big guys are
all working on it, right?
Spatial computing, everybody
wants their spatial engine.
And Amazon is doing their
thing, and Niantic, of course,
is well into it.
Magic Leap has
got the whatever--
I don't know all
the-- the magic verse.
Is that what they call it?
AUDIENCE: I never know what
Magic Leap [INAUDIBLE]..
HALSEY BURGUND:
(LAUGHING) Neither
do I. Neither do I. But
it seems like they're
spending a lot of
money, and they
got good people doing stuff.
AUDIENCE: They certainly
are spending a lot of money.
HALSEY BURGUND: Yes.
They got Neil
Stephenson doing stuff.
So they got some
content possibilities.
So yeah.
I mean, it's super exciting.
But we're definitely
dependent on the systems
that are out of my control,
out of most people's control.
But I think if you work
within those constraints,
you can still create
some pretty cool stuff.
AUDIENCE: Other questions?
HALSEY BURGUND: Other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In my
project, I wanted
to make something that people
could potentially contribute
poetry to a location.
So I think this might be
really helpful with that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
That's very cool.
Yeah, I think poetry can have
some wonderful, obviously,
a lot of the language can be
very physically put in a place.
And it would be nice to
actually be in that place, too.
Yeah, I did a piece.
It's no longer available because
of the inexorable progress
of new iOS versions and whatnot.
But I did a piece
in Harvard Yard
that, as the source material,
it used a bunch of audio
that the Woodberry Poetry
Room at Harvard had.
They've had a poetry series
for, like, a hundred years
of poets coming in and
reading their works.
So they had recordings of
Robert Frost and William Carlos
Williams and Ezra Pound--
really old, amazing
recordings of these
poets reading their work.
And then they have more
contemporary poets, as well.
And I took those, and I kind
of sliced them up line by line
and then distributed them
around in different places.
So I had all the first lines
of the poem in a certain area.
So if you went to this area,
you could hear first line
after first line
after first line.
Then you could go somewhere else
and hear all the last lines.
And it made it very abstract.
And the poets probably
would be very upset with me
if they found out about this.
But it was a remixing of
that, a spatial remixing,
which was pretty fun to do.
But I love your idea.
So were you thinking of having
people read their own poetry
or something along those lines?
So write a poem that related
to a certain location
and then go to that
location and kind of recite
it sort of thing?
Or I could imagine if you want
to share any more thoughts.
AUDIENCE: I was thinking about
while they're in the location,
creating a poem there.
HALSEY BURGUND: Oh, almost
like improv or something
like on the-- oh, yeah,
that could be really great.
So yeah, the question would be--
I mean, in a Roundware
context, that
would be open the
app, press Speak,
make up a poem right now.
And then you just
press record, and you
would record it and then
upload it to the cloud.
And then, whenever somebody else
came by, they could hear that.
And then you'd have
the ability, of course,
as an administrator in that
case to listen and move
the recording or make the area
bigger or those sorts of things
if you were to want to do that.
But that could be a
wonderful way of--
it would be a nice way to
traverse a city, right?
You kind of wander
through a city,
and you hear residents'
improvised poetry
at crosswalks or wherever.
That's a cool idea.
AUDIENCE: And you've been
working a lot on prompts,
right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HALSEY BURGUND: Oh, cool.
AUDIENCE: Things to sort of get
people who may not necessarily
appeal to [INAUDIBLE].
HALSEY BURGUND: That's really
smart to think about that.
Because that's really hard.
I mean, poetry is
particularly hard.
But even for me, to say
anything is sometimes hard.
So I always think about
what questions I ask.
And I usually have some
question that's so broad
that anybody could do it.
Like just tell a
story about your day.
I don't know.
Look at the ground and tell
me what it reminds you of.
I'm just sorry.
I'm making up bad
examples right now
but something that's very broad.
I mean, literally, it could
just be, share something.
Say something.
And then, as I go down the
list, I get into more details.
Because I find that
some people freak out
when they have a
super-broad question.
They're like, what do
you mean something?
What does that mean?
What is say something?
They are much
happier being given
instructions like, look at a
tree near you and describe it.
Then they're like,
OK, I can do that.
There's a tree.
Record.
The tree is quite tall, and
it's got lots of branches.
And the leaves
right now are green,
but they're starting
to turn yellow.
Some people are much more
comfortable with that.
So in a poetry context, that
could be really interesting.
What are some prompts that
you've come up with thus far?
Because that's a challenge.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Right now, I've just been
thinking about sound.
So it wasn't necessarily a
poem about sound but ask,
what sounds can
you hear right now?
What can you really [INAUDIBLE]?
For one test, I
asked them to write
a poem about a different subject
based on the sounds they heard.
HALSEY BURGUND: You mean
like a poem about sound
that isn't about what
that sound is, actually?
Like what it reminds you?
Is that what you're saying?
Sorry, I'm--
AUDIENCE: Kind of.
The theme is not necessarily
the sound itself.
HALSEY BURGUND: Right.
So what it reminds you
of or what it maybe
points towards or
something like that, yeah.
Yeah, no, that's
great to use sound.
Poetry is such a--
in my mind, poetry
is meant to be read.
It's got all the rhythms
and everything really
come out when it gets into the
audio from just the written
page.
I mean, the written page can
be really interesting, too.
But it's hard.
It's hard to just
make up a poem.
And it must rhyme!
AUDIENCE: I think that one's not
so strict on your [INAUDIBLE]
but a little bit
more free verse.
HALSEY BURGUND:
Yes, that's good.
That's good.
Yes, free form is--
I'm always impressed with free
form rap battles and stuff
like that.
I mean, obviously, M&M is the--
the 8 Mile thing, it's
just like, oh, my gosh.
How do they come
up with this stuff?
And I know a lot of it is--
I know there are strategies
and techniques that
make it more doable.
But my brain doesn't
work that way.
I can't just-- although it
sounds like it right now,
that I can just talk forever.
But I don't always--
not always able to.
AUDIENCE: If you write the
audio SDKs, you probably could.
HALSEY BURGUND: Yeah.
Right.
Oh, that reminds
me, I should also
mention that I have started a
new website called audioar.org.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we
got your Webpost for--
HALSEY BURGUND: Oh,
great, great, great.
So the site is in its
infancy right now.
I've started it with a
couple colleagues, a couple
journalists, and Fran, who
came here a few months ago--
Fran Panetta.
AUDIENCE: A month ago.
HALSEY BURGUND: A month ago?
To talk to you guys.
British.
You probably remember
because her very perfect
British accent.
So she has been doing
audio AR stuff, obviously,
as you know, for a while, too.
So we started this
site just to try
to collect different
practitioners in the area.
And it felt like something
was starting-- companies,
obviously.
Bose and Amazon and Apple and
others are getting interested.
And we thought it would be a
nice place to let practitioners
and technologists and academics
and other people share
their experiences, things
that work, things that
didn't work, and let people
know when projects are happening
and whatnot.
So we're ramping up on that.
And Philip has agreed to
be interviewed for that,
at some point, whenever
I get myself in gear.
I promise I will, and I'm
looking forward to that.
AUDIENCE: No rush.
HALSEY BURGUND: Yeah, I know.
You're like, please forget.
[LAUGHS] No.
But yeah, any
projects you guys do,
and we'd love to think about
getting stuff up there.
Because I think this class
is evidence of the fact
that it is becoming
a real thing, which
is really exciting.
So I'm super excited to
hear or to experience
what you guys choose
to do with the class.
Is a project sort of the
deliverable for the class?
AUDIENCE: Right.
So there will be a presentation.
We need to discuss
that before you leave,
when it's going to happen.
Because there are
possible changes there.
But there will be a presentation
at the end of the class.
Francesca will hopefully attend.
Some people from
Bose will attend.
If you can come,
that would be great.
HALSEY BURGUND: Oh, cool.
Yeah, yeah, keep me posted.
AUDIENCE: Otherwise, we'll
spend the next two weeks
thinking through
how to disseminate
our insights from the class.
So there will be something
online, I dare say.
But we will try to
decide that together,
exactly what form it will take.
So there will be something.
We will leave a trace.
HALSEY BURGUND: Well,
to the extent possible,
we'd love to amplify that
message on audioar.org
if it's possible.
But we can obviously
talk about that.
But yeah.
So if you guys have any
ideas about things to include
or practitioners or whatever,
please feel free to reach out.
Because we are super open and
want to learn from each other.
AUDIENCE: So we're
running out of time,
but I am very curious about
one aspect of the system.
Is it dynamic in
any way that people
who make contribution
could actually
change parameters or aspects of
the experience for other people
beyond just the sound
trace they leave?
So an example would
be like if there's
a lot of people leaving--
I don't know why I decided
to call them sound traces--
but if a lot of people
leave sound traces
in the same location,
can the system
detect that take and
decide to play sort
of a more multi-layered
ambient soundtrack in that area
or something, some way of being
aware of what's being inputed?
HALSEY BURGUND: That's a
really interesting area
to think about.
The simple answer
right now is no,
in the sense that
Roundware doesn't--
I mean, Roundware, you
can choose how many
simultaneous voices can play.
And therefore, if you say,
well, three simultaneous voices
can play if three
are available, then,
in that sense, if there's a
location where people add more,
then that will be a location
where, potentially, three
will--
if there's a
hundred in the spot,
you'll probably have
three playing altogether
at any given time.
That's not the music
layer or whatever.
That's just the--
whereas if you have
a spot that only has one
available, even though three
could potentially
play at the same time,
only one will ever actually
play because there's
only one available.
So that's a very, very
rudimentary aspect
of what you were talking about.
And that's the only--
at least if I'm
understanding you correctly--
that's the only thing that
Roundware does currently.
But I love this idea.
I hadn't thought about this.
I love this idea
of more activity,
the heat map heats up and
something changes with--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we
are always trying
to think about is
there a way I can
program this as a participant?
Because we're at MIT.
So there might be a way, even
if you don't know it, injecting
code some weird way by--
HALSEY BURGUND: Yeah, who knows?
AUDIENCE: --overloading
the database or something.
But it's just I think there is
some potential there somewhere.
It could be very
advanced, like the words
you say could actually be
understood by the system,
and it could change things.
Then, yeah, you're
halfway to The Matrix.
HALSEY BURGUND: I don't know.
I've been thinking
about the first step
to that, obviously,
is getting some kind
of accurate translation
or transcription service
automated.
And then you could
get to the point
where you could
search for only play
me commentary that
uses the word "love."
And then you could walk around
and get this whole experience
with just--
and then you do
sentiment analysis.
And then it's like only give
me the comments that feel love,
even though they don't say
love, but they feel it.
So I think those are
super-exciting areas
to look into.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I just want
to know what the zombie
people would do with
something like that,
right, where they can
affect the system itself.
HALSEY BURGUND: Or the
zombies themselves.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HALSEY BURGUND: Yeah, this
is very, very important.
But I love that idea.
And yeah.
So it's open source.
You go for it.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: We're out of time.
This was really helpful.
Actually, we have one
team who are out today
because of medical emergencies
that are basically doing
the kind of Pokmon
GO with music.
HALSEY BURGUND: Oh, cool.
AUDIENCE: So we'll definitely
have them look at your system.
And they, I would guess,
will want to use it.
HALSEY BURGUND: Well,
feel free to reach out.
I can, again, depending on
the level of technical skill
and time involved,
or time available,
I can recommend different
approaches to things.
But all the code is there.
The server is written
in Python using Django.
Obviously, iOS is Swift.
And the web stuff is
very nascent right now,
but it's all JavaScript, sort
of modern-day JavaScript stuff.
So to the extent.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
But is there a way to
procedurally generate
a location for a sound
byte, or is it totally tied?
HALSEY BURGUND: Can you
describe what scenario?
Like, what input would
you be taking to--
AUDIENCE: So this has to
do with the Pokmon GO,
like audio music project
that Chuck was doing.
Chuck and?
AUDIENCE: Terese?
AUDIENCE: Terese, yeah--
Chuck and Terese are doing.
Anyway, so in Pokmon
GO, you walk around.
Pokmon spawn, Can
audio also spawn--
AUDIENCE: The probability--
AUDIENCE: --based
on a probability?
HALSEY BURGUND: Yeah.
That would be the
kind of thing that
would be a relatively
small modification
for a particular project.
I haven't done that.
The other thing that I
haven't done that I'm
very excited about is moving.
After their spawn,
then they move.
You assign a path and a time,
whatever, and they loop around.
So then, you can just
sit in one place,
and you can let
stuff flow over you.
Or you can move
around, and there's
this sort of double
interaction in that sense.
So it's a single
interaction, but you know
what I mean-- double motion.
So that kind of dynamism,
I think, is very exciting.
But yeah, I like the idea of
spawning, sort of popping up,
based on maybe your
previous experience
within the app or
something like that.
But yeah, I think the framework
is there that you can--
I've been just
adding stuff as we
go, semi-organic codebase
in that sense, which
is sometimes problematic.
But it's fairly clean.
So check it out.
If you know Python, you can jump
in and have a look, all right?
AUDIENCE: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
It's been--
HALSEY BURGUND: Thank
you guys so much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]